you know I really I hate to waste your
time but I'm really not looking to do
more advertising right now yeah no I'm
sorry
yeah I know Dory's I hear that okay that
gives me a certain amount of relief
thank you thank you I'm in the sweet
spot and controlling not just me too
baby let's go into the kill jack you're
known all over town as the guy with a
dick in his mouth
right well it's not just dicks
no no not nothing boobs yes seem to I
have to I've seen it but pooping boobs
yep yep being Andre the Giant I've seen
that don't get it but I've seen it let's
not forget about the speech bubble yes
yes I'm hungry for turd that's right by
my church I'm thirsty for dong feed me
wieners you think it's just one guy no
jack but we at Kremlin duvet and put an
end all that nonsense by rebranding you
in a television commercial to be honest
the billboards don't really bother me
okay I actually I I think they're kind
of funny you knowing young man I know
what you're doing you're busted yeah
that's great you're using force
perspective to make it look like I'm
fellating that breadstick grow up grow
up oh and there we go
dinner roll balls dinner roll balls
really original you know what I am tired
of this sign me up
let's do this man damn babe a beer yeah
horn honking see Jeff bring us your
problem man why I'm really excited right
Milton good know JB Dre Jackson follow
[Music]